[Music]
you went places in this book that I
didn't expect you to go you got so much
more candid in this one than the first
one what change between when you wrote
the first book and the second book that
you were able to go to that place this
time
unfortunately I'm I'm sure you've heard
I lost my mom so you know that got me
really upset and angry and that's what
made me open up because I felt like I
lost out those 11 and a half months that
I was in prison it could have been with
my mom was 11 and 1/2 months and I guess
all those feelings came out which I have
to say was really therapeutic when I
wrote the book and I felt like it was
good to get it all out it was one of the
worst times in my life I mean I would go
away 20 more times then you know not to
lose my mom you know it was just her
birthday yes I'm still numb over like I
still I still feel like it's not real
the day of her birthday that morning I
got woken up and I heard this animal in
my room like with this screeching sound
like I'm not kidding like I thought
there was an actual like some kind of
animal in my room
I put the flashlight on you know on my
iPhone and I was like trying to see what
it was and it was I think it was my mom
it was like the first time I feel like
she came to me like I'm exactly like
she's not gonna come to me like the way
she was but I do feel like that was my
mom that that day and it was on her
birthday and I knew it was gonna be a
hard day for me and it was it was a very
emotional day for my father my brother
and myself it was a hard day it was my
mom love you
I have to say this is one of the hardest
seasons for me because it starts off
with losing my mom it really is I still
haven't had a chance to enjoy the show
just because it's been one thing after
another and but I mean I have to say
this season if it wasn't for the other
girl it's like they help me get through
it because otherwise I think I'd have
just crumbled after losing my mom so
they helped me get through and they kept
my mind busy